ma buongiorno a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti simi a questo nuovo video
visto che ho fatto uscire cleverbot
sabato scorso ho detto questo sabato
perché non fare un po di sé vie termine
sarebbe come come lo spirito lievi e
questo questo è e vi è il gioco di
cleverbot con una persona che è
effettivamente un robot ma che ti
risponde ed è molto molto tripi per chi
non lo conoscesse ricordo se parla
italiano parli italiano a rhymes pirica
e l'italia in italia che è perfetto come
stai
madonna non seguite
questo è proprio italiano ti ricordi
come si parla italiano
no
merda sono vari geni ti ricordi di me
non mi ricordo come non ti ricordi porca
vacca parigi o cielo un arco
ricominciate vie avevamo fatto un video
insieme ricordi del tipo ma cattivo come
farà ricordare
era un video in cui
mi hai pure rimorchiatore mario
che cosa si diano al margine senza la
pena tanto non c'è nero e non c'è lo
stato che è stato fidanzato per i
presenti hanno antica io mi ricordo dei
tre punti sono falli j1 youtube piacere
sarei presentato
davvero certo sono proprio io tu come ti
chiami facciamo le presentazioni a
questo punto che l h ho già detto prima
quello il polacco ha dato nome capito
nomi italiani come piante come piove di
questi giovanotti si l'ora in frigo
fanno piacere che ti piace jovanotti ma
anche mio amico è molto bravo e lo stimo
tantissimo
io mi chiamo lorenzo anche che bel nome
amore
allora in questo momento sto sto facendo
un video il mio canale iva di salutare i
miei iscritti sarà mai più rivederci
perfetto è rimasta socievole come
ricordava bene c'è qualcosa che posso
fare per riuscire ad acquisire la tua
amicizia non mettermi alla prova
delle maniere dolci vista una ragazza
allora
ti trovo molto simpatica
grazie ma che ho detto qua così il
polacco che non ho capito però a parte
quello che si fa tu mi trovi simpatico
no per niente eletto grazie vi è almeno
mi trovi carino no grazie grazie grazie
grazie grazie e vi arriva un
appuntamento dall io sono di milano dove
se in questa come stazione molto più
vera di quella con cleverbot incredibile
sia in di sono seduto sono sono seduto
posso venire a casa tua anche adesso
sì certo che tu noi se tesoro per almeno
un attimo voglio capire le intenzioni
che c'ha quindi capiamo cosa vuoi fare
a casa.la muri l amore in realtà non si
ferisce all'amore dei sonohra ma ald
that not anch'io penso che sia un gran
ragazzo bello soprattutto ma
simpaticissimo in che modo vuoi fare
perché sei fi così ho capito questo
questo lo sa ma usiamo il costo non devi
diventare incinta e anche lei ha dei
problemi nel capire che io
effettivamente non è che fosse di
valeggio però non posso rimanere in
cinque io al massimo i
cimiteri massimo tu sei un rubaie non
sono roba poi gli ho comunque uso il 3
per questo vivo in mischia cosa vuol
dire
se sei trasferite in messico
preventivamente bellissimo siamo
conoscerci prima o k cup piacere roberto
roberto ma mica c'hai la sorpresa
ed
elogiato ho un mio amico
che si chiama rocco mi ha spiegato in un
sacco di cose lo sai lui che mi ha
spiegato un sacco di così mal ha
spiegato lui mi ha detto una volta che
se entro il camera phone all'aria ho una
buona percentuale riuscita non ho detto
che è bello e non so che è quindi non
parlo di persone che non conosco rocco
lo conoscono tutti cambiamo totalmente
argomento che la cambiamo argomento
sciandra senti mar tu cosa fai studi
basta andiamo al punto da un nuovo fare
cose con calma calma calma ti voglio
solo sapere cosa fai nella vita studio
che berti qua cosa studi con i prati
questo speriamo che se fai pure schifo
lavati comunque l'igiene la dovrebbe
studiare un sacco di gente secondo me
quindi fai bene bravo e strisce cosa
vorresti voglio baciare nicchi mina non
è questo e altro discorso ma cosa
vorresti fare di lavoro spiega mi
interessa stare così ti posso pagare sta
con me che cazzo di un mestiere scusa
devo andare a farmi una doccia vuoi
venire anche tu di igiene quindi mi
rendo conto che tu ad so che stai
facendo i compiti in questo momento
volendo volendo ma nudi perché
vengo a casa tua e la faccia nudo
direttamente
e vieni vieni aspetta che mi spara
vuoi da bere
ma che diavolo vai vi chiedono l'accesso
vabbè voglio da bere dopo la doccia
perché faremo un sacco di zoom zoom
quanta sweet
candy ai got a special sweet candy for
you
quindi abbiamo abbiamo sbirciato
l'inglese yuan
il contrario o addio no ai contanti
john
candy il the shower a domenica grazie
thanks god sentieri e grazie per la
conversazione di niente quindi adesso
facciamo così all'ascolto ma fa accussi
io ho finisco di fare il video e poi
vengono ben ti aspetta il momento ti
aspetto bene bene mi aspetta allora
aiutami a
concludere il video per favore che
evidente i 2 milioni di youtube sto
registrando
adesso saluta perché perché c'è un sacco
di gente che mi segue che deriva si
vergogna si vergognava medail aiuto io
aiuto e rotella a tutti i ragazzi si fa
tesa non scritto così però più o meno
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
mettete mi piace
mi piace e noi ci rivediamo a grossi
prossimo
della sea
race anche ivey e riesce a chiudere il
video pazzesco ora c'è un appuntamento
ragazzi non posso far tardare la signora
però i vi sia piaciuto ragazzi consenso
di processo non mi piace perché dice mia
amica perché lo dico io era come sempre
ci vediamo hanno proseguito è da ragazzi
[Musica]